[Music]
you have some ideas in your head about
what it means to be a father but now
that I am going to be a father there's a
lot of fear honestly
[Music]
all right
rookie dads when you walk into the
classroom it's intense
there's a lot of diapers crying and
we're all nervous we don't know what to
expect take a good look at Nick here
this is your ghost of Christmas future
these guys last six months is what your
next six months looks like okay helping
these guys prepare for their future as
dads is basically about providing them
with some really simple insights mom's
like facing the babies dads tend to turn
the babies around face the babies out
into the world we talked about how dad
is instinctively wired to be a protector
and a simple preparation now it can
dramatically change how things happen in
the future you are going into a nesting
phase - you're actually gonna go through
about a 33 percent drop in testosterone
it'll come back it'll come back there
are so many things that concern me about
becoming a parent even things like how
to hold your baby properly and I'm just
keeping the house up around us and the
ground underneath us it's hard to
overstate how pivotal the preparation is
that we have these guys do and set her
right there before he lets her go and
wrap her up like this okay
quite a significant percentage of the
guys who come to this class I've never
held a baby before yeah it wasn't
expecting actually hold someone else's
child it's an immediate reality check
[Music]
and see if it's a watershed moment this
guy who's never held a baby who forces
wait a second I I'm doing this before
that walked into the classes of rookie I
probably would have said that I was
prepared it was only after I took the
class that I came out realizing wow I
don't know anything better and dad's
really were very open about their
experiences and passed around their
children to complete strangers very
brave the best way to prepare for your
kids future financially or emotionally
or spiritually is to take the time to
get your stuff together the box stops
with you right that's the role that
you're stepping into as a parent we've
got this square dance going on this is
kind of fun
last thing I do at boot camp Fernandez
is I asked a really simple question what
are two words you want your child to say
about you when they have a chance I hope
that it would answer that I was loving
and that I was patient yeah that's a
good question I know that it's an
opportunity to grow and be sure that you
are in a position to lead someone to the
Future you feel they deserve whether
you're a rookie parent or a veteran New
York Life has you covered start a plan
that flexes with yours